Trevor Zegras turn every night
into a highlight reel night.
At Jackpotcity.net,
we know how
to build you the best casino,
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET A GOOD
BREAKOUT.
THEY SUPPORT EACH OTHER WELL..
OPPORTUNITY FOR TANEV,GARY FLAM.
MIKAEL BACKLUND, TOP SHELF, AND
IT'S 3-1 FOR THE CALGARY FLAMES!
DO.
THEY GET IT BELOW THE GOAL LINE,
BEAUTIFUL GOAL BY LEON
ANANSHOT, QUICK
POSITION.
HE'S LOOKING TO SEE WHEN HE'S
[ Crowd Noise ]
[ Cheers and Applause ]
UP THE LATE OPTION AND OLIVER
KYLINGTON.
HIS D P P NECESSARILY ABOUT
FINDING SOME ROOM AND SETTING
THINGS UP.
REGARD, AND AGAIN, IT'S CHRIS
[ Horn ]CT
AND THEN SOME.
BUT JUST WATCH, WHEN CONNN
QUICK PASS TO McDAVID!
THE
PUCK UP ICE.
BUT
ELIAS LINDHOLM!
AND IT'S A
FORECHECK AND THEY CREATE A
TURNOVER.
IT'S A BUT WATCH HOW MUCH TIME
SPACE MIKAEL BACKLUND IS GIVEN.
IT'S A TURNOVER AT THE OFFENSIV
THERE FOR A LITTLE BIT, AND DUBE
FINDS IT AND PUTS IT